this is the 20th anniversary 20th year
of the chain reaction first of all I
want to introduce in case you have not
met Jeff Lieberman our illustrious
co-host Jeff Jeff is a wonderful
engineer inventor and kinetic sculptor
in this area and it is he's also a dear
friend please check out his work he does
amazing work
Jeff Lieberman amazing amazing work I do
amazing work that was largely inspired
by seeing Arthur's work 23 years ago at
the MIT Museum so now's a good time for
a plug that you can come from here and
go straight into the MIT Museum right
for free yes today's the day so check
out if you go there now you'll see like
all the works that I saw when I was in
high school where I first was exposed to
Arthur's work which is the room you know
not to over over do credit here but it's
like the main reason that I got into
making art work as my living so pretty
pretty amazing exhibit pretty amazing
work if you haven't gone and see it it's
incredible cheers for the gansan exhibit
yeah and the invention and invention the
infection of invention continues it
grows out I have a little list of things
a little list of thank yous because I
don't want to forget anybody here first
of all thank you to the MIT audio and
visual crew Justin and Joe they're
responsible for all the audio today
an MVP MIT video production and today we
have Craig Charles Eric and Elliot thank
you guys for your amazing work these
guys on the cameras they're incredible
it's very difficult to do what they do
again Ted and Mary Wilson from Michigan
shirt works they've been selling
t-shirts over there and they were
donating a percentage of their profits
for the MIT Museum educational
programming so thank you guys and for
the amazing shirts a huge thank you to
all the volunteers volunteers can you
raise your hands all the volunteers
I guess maybe they're working over there
this this event could cannot happen with
all the people that are volunteering and
there's like at least 20 volunteers
today here so thank you all for that and
there are also many many people this
this event could not happen without the
dedicated work of the MIT Museum staff
Jenny Devaney and Brenda when I've been
over there and there are many other
staff members that are working the
tables today and they're in and out so
they're there are the people that do all
the grunt work so thank you to all of
you folks
and of course a huge thank you to all of
the creative souls that have made these
incredible things that we're about to
watch thank you
it's it's impossible to calculate how
many hours of work has gone into
everything that you see here I couldn't
I couldn't wage a guess but it's it's
it's incredible work and I think that
this year I feel like there's extra
energy into what we've seen there are so
many things that we haven't seen before
so thank you for the the spirit and the
creative passion that you've put into
what you've brought here today we really
appreciate it yeah
if you're not if you're not clear on the
format what we do is we ask everybody
every team to make a section of the
chain reaction and then all of these
sections are linked by pull strings so
we ask everybody to end their reaction
by pulling a string and to have their
reactions start by a string pull and
that ends up being a very simple
language by which we can communicate the
transmission of energy throughout the
entire cycle and this is the first time
this is the first and last time that
anybody will ever see this chain
reaction and I think that's pretty
remarkable noting the individual pieces
have been tested mostly but the entire
thing we don't know what's going to
happen so that's that's a lot of the fun
of it and occasionally this the spirit
behind the work that everybody's doing
or I believe it's not about it's not
about being perfect but it's about
exploration and taking chances and when
you're on the edge when you take chances
with something very often it doesn't
work and in this case it's okay if
something doesn't work perfectly it
doesn't matter because if the spirit is
there then it's a success if you see
occasionally you'll see a little finger
or a hand help something and I like to
call that the hand of God intervening so
in that sense there's no there's no
break to the chain reaction no matter
what happens it's all running the way it
should be
yeah okay okay because this is the 20th
year we would like to have Jenny Novotny
from the MIT Museum staff she has put
together a video and she's going to say
something about her reflections as she
did that fantastic thank you guys all
for joining us today as you have heard
many times this is our 20th chain
reaction the chain reaction started in
the MIT Museum we were actually in the
galleries perhaps bouncing into exhibits
and as you can imagine we quickly
outgrew our space we moved next door to
du Pont du Pont gymnasium and then moved
in here in 2004 a couple of other big
moments in our life in 2009
Arthur created a time capsule of the
chain reaction experience perhaps one
day we'll learn when the chain reaction
we open it we'll see we'll see in 2014
Jeff joined us as a co MC and we have
been rolling along ever since I
interrupt you for one second okay -
speaking of Jeff
[Music]
yeah this was kind of like
long-forgotten history but then I had a
chance to preview what the video that
Jenny's about to show you and the one
thing that really struck me that I
remembered was I was a student at the
time the first reaction happened and I
built the first section of the first
years chain reaction that ever fired and
then I stopped being a student and I
only came back when it was the 17th one
and we were co-hosting so somehow I've
been involved since the first moment of
the first chain reaction anyone else who
is that the first chain reaction okay
all right I'll be enough perfect so we
are going to show a video for people who
are standing in front of the bleachers
we do ask that you sit down so everyone
can see the screens so if you are in
front of bleachers please do sit down
and with that we'd love to see the video
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and is it
yeah okay here we are in order to kick
this year's off I am going to invite my
son Kat to come out and help start it
cool I got double mics now okay while
they're setting up it's a very rare
thing to have this many people spending
time together in a room right we do this
with our families we just had our
Thanksgiving dinner and we're gonna do a
drum roll and a countdown but I also
just wanted to take a second and what's
really really rare is for hundreds of
people in a room together to just be in
a room together not doing anything some
of you have spent the last six hours
preparing for this moment so it's like a
really full moment we're all in intense
anticipation and so I just want to take
like 20-30 seconds for us to sit in
silence and then they're gonna begin the
drum roll which is going to begin the
countdown and we're going to count down
from 20 seconds and I'll start it and
it'll be obvious but I'm gonna try to do
it with them when they get going so I'm
gonna tell them to give us a drumroll in
about 30 seconds and for everyone to
just enjoy this final silent moment
before this raucous cacophonous thing is
about to happen
okay drum roll please
[Music]
okay everyone 20 19 18 17 16 15 14 13 12
11 10 9 8 7 6 5 4 3 2 1 all right
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
for those of you who guessed three
minutes sorry Nick better luck next time
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
yes
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
pay no attention to the man behind the
curtain
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh but not a little pull this thing a
little bit
[Applause]
[Applause]
hey nice
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
ignore that
keep the timer going please
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
like a really long time
yes
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
hello hello okay that was 28 minutes and
nine seconds yeah thank you
thank you to all of the chain reactors
please raise your hands everybody
everybody who made something thank you
so much
you guys are great you guys are amazing
thank you to everybody who showed up you
guys are great too
now jenny is gonna tell you could
announce the winners excellent
so our chain reaction ran a total length
of 28 minutes and nine seconds so the
winner is Chelsea Sebastian and you can
go to the information table for your
prize we also have a few other prizes
from the activities so if one a who got
the fastest time for the sack race
Destin and Phoebe are who got the top
hula hoop times and Brandon Dee who won
the jump roping contest you can also go
to the information table and get your
prizes
thank you all hope to see you next year
have a great day
thank you everyone